streamlined plots ignoring lore and
cutting characters might spice things up
on screen but these changes to the Dune
films left fans of the original book
wanting so much more
in the novel Frank Herbert frames the
story with narration from Princess
Ireland while Herbert's prose jumps
between the story's main players notes
from Ireland's diegetic writing serve as
the glue holding the ambitious plot
together epigraphs for me ruin's later
works of History give color to each
chapter these stylistic flourishes give
The Narrative of Dune the flavor of an
official account taken from within its
own Universe while both the 1984 and
2021 adaptations include narration they
both feature different narrators in
David Lynch's 1984 film princess irulin
played by Virginia Madsen introduces the
universe of Dune and quickly explains
the importance of spice before the
opening title in denial nuv's 2021
version a voiceover from Shawnee opens
the movie and introduces the struggle of
the fremin people to the audience her
narration is represented as part of the
ongoing dreams consuming Paul Atreides
in each film The narration gets the
audience up to speed on the conflict
over melange also known as spice Drive
students Universe while neither film's
narrations serve the same purpose as Ira
lands in the novel both versions do
attempt to give an entry point point to
the enormous world the audience enters
it'll be interesting to see how much of
this changes when Florence Pew's
princess Ireland appears in Dune part 2.
Gurney holik War Master of the House of
Trades appears in both the 1984 and 2021
adaptations while both films represent
the character's loyalty and Military
might neither quite Nails the characters
Warrior poet traits in the novel holic
is often reciting poetry singing or
playing an instrument called the balaset
music then no music in both films
directors Lynch and velnov seem to
stress the character's Warrior side more
than his poetic aspect the 1984 version
with Patrick Stewart starring his holic
uses Stewart's natural theatrical talent
to smooth out Alex hardened edges in the
2021 adaptation Josh Brolin plays holic
is all business
smile Gurney
and smiling
in a round table with reporters vilnov
confirmed that he actually did film a
scene of halek playing and singing the
battle set but opted to cut it for part
one
not many people make movies quite like
David Lynch for an example of Lynch's
one-of-a-kind influence on his Dune
adaptation fans need to look no further
than the heart plugs worn by the Harkin
and servants from their initial
appearance Lynch wastes no time ensuring
that the audience is immediately
repelled by the hearken and brood just
when viewers think the Harkin and boys
can't get any grosser the bearing calls
the servants with a brass key surgically
implanted into his chest into the room
after accosting the boy the baron
removes the key blood comes pouring out
and the servant dies in true Lynch
fashion the heart plugs are never
explained or even mentioned however the
visceral nature of the device is so
grotesque that the behold it tells the
audience everything they need to know
about the harkenings only a mad Genius
Like Lynch could buy something that
makes these villains even more vile than
Frank Herbert ever did lynch also opens
his Dune with a meeting between the
emperor of the known universe panasha
Emperor Saddam Carino IV and a spacing
Guild Navigator the scene does not
appear in the novel but it quickly
establishes Lynch's vision for a dune
universe that looks like a combination
of sci-fi pulp covers and abstract
painting even though the scenes
essentially an exposition dump Lynch's
Bizarro creature in set design make a
dialogue heavy scene a grotesque treat
to watch
Duncan Idaho's chemistry with Paul his
physicality during fight sequences and
moments of levity bring a ton of energy
to Jason momoa's character
me yeah I want some muscle
I did no
Idaho is a fan favorite so when he dies
at the hands of sardicar Warriors it's
no surprise that it's an emotional
highlight and a standout action set
piece all at once in the novel however
Idaho's death occurs during a chapter
following Paul's perspective so Paul in
the audience don't get to see Idaho's
last stand against the starter car the
film also raises the emotional Stakes of
Idaho's death by having Idaho close the
door between the Atreides and the
sardicar Paul seals the door himself in
the book small changes like these are
what give Idaho's death its wall up on
the big screen the love spends a sizable
portion of the First Act developing the
relationship between Duncan and Paul
because the relationship is better
developed on screen the audience feels
the impact the decision has on Paul when
Duncan sacrifices himself to save the
young Duke after losing all of his
father figures Paul must prepare to take
responsibility for his survival the
future of House of tradies and
eventually a battle with the harkenings
the 2021 version of Dune does a lot of
work to put the first to trades family
at the center of the story this helps
audiences empathize with a good and
Noble Atreides and despise the
Despicable and grotesque carcinids
however focusing on the family members
also means giving less attention to some
of the family's key advisors like the
mentats in the novel mentas for House of
tradies and house harkinen advise the
leaders of both houses and figure more
prominently in the plot mentas are
essential because their continued
consumption of the spice melange turns
their brains into supercomputers they're
responsible for all things involving
strategy probability and Logistics while
the mentats were both War infections are
included in the film neither receives
much screen time in fact the characters
are never even called mentats on screen
so I failed you today there's no excuse
you have my resignation in an interview
with the Los Angeles Times villanov
explained that cutting down on
characters like the mentas was a
deliberate choice to ground the first
movie more in Paul's experience
the fremin the indigenous people of
Iraqis have many interesting Traditions
yet to be explored in the latest
adaptation it's likely more their
Customs will be explored in part two but
the first film passes on a chance to
depict an important ceremony
with our knife chip and shudder like the
film adaptation the novel sees Paul duo
with James however after James's death
in the novel Herbert dedicates all of
chapter 34 to presenting a fremin
funeral and its implications for Paul
from in funerals or water preservation
ceremonies are all about water during
the ritual Jameis water is distilled
into a bulging sack weighed and
reclaimed as the tribe's water which
shows just how important water is to the
fremin while the latest adaptation of
the water preservation ceremony may not
appear until Dune part 2 any curious
viewers can check out Lynch's take on
the ceremony which appeared in a deleted
scene
both the 1984 and 2021 Dune adaptations
cast actors who were older than their
counterparts in the novel In the book
characters like Paul fade routa of house
harkening and shiny kinds are all part
of the up-and-coming generation behind
current leaders making the Story a
coming-of-age tale Paul is 15 years old
at the beginning of the novel
interestingly enough the actors playing
Paul in both films Kyle McLaughlin in
1984 and Timothy chalamet in 2021 were
both in their mid-20s when their
versions were released the same goes for
its female leads Johnny has been
portrayed twice on the big screen by
women in their mid-20s Sean Young a
Blade Runner Fame in 1984 in Zendaya in
the latest adaptation McLaughlin and
young in particular simply don't pass as
teenagers while the pair's performances
fit well into Lynch's absolutely Gonzo
sci-fi Vision their apparent age makes
the story seem centered around the
adults in the 2021 version the leads
look young enough to be older teens so
the coming of age story present in the
novel remains in the more recent film
one of the most compelling features of
Dune is its preoccupation with
hand-to-hand combat by envisioning a
world where most combatants Rock a
projectile proof body Shield Frank
Herbert created a necessity for blades
while the latest adaptation contained
several scenes showing the importance of
sword knife fighting in the Dune
Universe David Lynch's version goes a
different route
the weirding module a weapon which
essentially turns sound into a
weaponized laser beam doesn't appear in
Herbert's novel The Weapon Services a
stand-in for the martial arts and Powers
practiced by The Witches of the Benny
Jesuit known as the weirding way Lynch
turns the weirding way into a means to
deal out physical damage with one's
voice in other words a 1984 version
replaces the Benny jesuit's unique
combat abilities with voice activated
ray guns this change ends up
de-emphasizing the importance of
hand-to-hand combat in the movie the
attention to Blade combats is a huge
part of what makes a book's vision of
the far future so fascinating and
different from other sci-fi worlds
luckily for fans a 2021 adaptation did
away with the weirding modules and
delivered some truly epic sword fights
in the book Paul's Nemesis fade ralpha
appears the first time readers encounter
the harkinens while router is present
throughout Lynch's version he is
entirely absent from Bill knows 2021
adaptation ralpha is an awesome villain
because he acts as a twisted reflection
of Paul like Paul ratha is a skilled
Warrior extremely intelligent and The
Heir Apparent to a powerful family
unlike Paul rauta is also one sick puppy
in the book he spars to the death with
Harkin and slaves for fun he was also
raised by the most cunning ruthless and
power-hungry Uncle to ever wear
anti-gravity pads Baron Vladimir
harkinen while Paul struggles to wield
his new power for all things good routa
can't wait to seize power to do all
things bad all I can see
is in a tradies that I want to kill
well some fans might have been
disappointed with ralpha's absence in
the latest adaptation they can rest
assured he'll appear in the sequel Elvis
star Austin Butler is taking on the role
fans of the novel will likely notice
that Baron's full plot to undermine
House of tradies is streamlined in both
the 2021 and 1984 adaptations of Dune
the book goes into a lot more detail
about The Baron's full scheme to reclaim
arrakis the linchpin of the Barons plan
is Dr UA Wellington UA is the trusted
in-house physician of House of tradies
the baron has Dr UA's wife Juana
abducted to gain leverage over the
doctor however the baron also plans to
sew Discord in the Atreides Camp by
pitting the Atreides mentat against Duke
lato etrady's wife Jessica the idea is
that a tradies human computer in
Resident which will be too busy snooping
on each other to pick up Dr UA's scent
while it's hard to know exactly why some
plot threads are cut and others are kept
during adaptations both film versions
streamline the Barons plot to focus
solely on UA this isn't necessarily a
bad thing as Dr UA's storyline is both
compelling and tragic however
simplifying The Baron's plan Paints the
baron to be a bit more ruthless than he
is cunning he's still terrifying to
behold in any version but he definitely
reads a bit smarter on the page Dune is
a best-selling type novel for many
reasons but its deep lore is definitely
a strong selling point for fans one
aspect of the novel's lore that hasn't
made it to the big screen in its
entirety is the universe's detailed
economic system although Lynch's version
did mention it in a deleted scene we
know
yet we are the secret
the Dune universe is ruled by the
potasha emperor and governed by the
Council of great houses called the
landsrad all of these houses including
the Imperial house participate in the
open market of trading goods and
services across the Galaxy because the
Dune universe is ruled by money much
like our own real political power comes
from a given House's stake in the
combine ownette oberer advancer
mercantiles or the chome company
essentially any house with a bigger
piece of choms pie than the emperor can
shirk his Rule and do whatever they want
the conquest for economic Supremacy
drives the plot as much as any of its
other Essential Elements while it's
definitely a complex system it gives
Herbert's Universe a level of specific
detail a lot of other sci-fi properties
lack both film adaptations have
simplified the complexities of
interstellar economics but maybe Dune
part 2 will introduce the chome company
to the Delight of dedicated fans
everywhere
foreign